all the women are changing what the men
don't care about the men don't care
about the big old lips yes they do and
no they do it the women are doing that
for themselves yeah because the men
don't care about it the men would rather
a woman change your stinking attitude
then put on all that makeup and hair and
everything that's what the men want but
the women that go out there like oh I'm
gonna change this I'm gonna change that
if you look at a man and a man said yeah
he's fat the man with muscle if he's
feeling bad about himself he wants to
make that he'll go and hit the gym
what's going to do go and do get a BBL
get her lips done putting her makeup put
on their hair and stayed a big old fat
person actually isn't say oh it's body
positivity the men don't even want that
the women are not getting all this
cosmetic surgery for the men they're
getting it for themselves yeah you can't
turn around what man wants a woman that
gonna turn around go and have an
operation they can't sit on a plane
because their ass has been injected or
been interfered with she's got a lie
there on her stomach you've written the
men want that or wake up in the morning
before you gotta hit the house she's
gonna put on I'm sure